now we turn to a conspiracy theory
that's become a deadly weapon in
russia's war on ukraine the kremlin
claims without any evidence that the u.s
has helped ukraine develop biological
weapons in secret laboratories chris
livesay got exclusive access to a
ukrainian lab at the heart of this
information war to check out the bogus
claims that some americans including
members of congress actually believe
it's here russia says where ukraine and
the united states are developing
biological weapons a secret lab that in
this leafy neighborhood isn't so
sinister after all
that's rambo the only security at
keeve's public reference laboratory
we're the first journalists allowed
inside since russia's invasion but it's
routinely inspected by international
agencies like the who
natalia vedaco chief of research shows
us equipment for containing some of the
most infectious diseases known to
humankind cholera anthrax
not to make weapons she tells us but to
test for diseases in patients
i see so you use it to identify the
pathogen in other people correct
absolutely
but that all changed once the russian
army invaded ukraine so there's been
active shelling in this area
since the war you've destroyed all of
the strains yes because it was very high
biological risk if this building was
attacked that could have been dangerous
if those strains had gotten loose if if
for there will be these yes it's
possible so you put the pathogens in
here yes this special program
and it destroys them yes it makes them
so that they can't hurt yes of course by
order of the government she says all
particularly dangerous strains and
ukrainian labs were killed of course
you're familiar with the accusations
from russia that this laboratory and
others like it have been developing
biological weapons
this crazy fake
non-fact non-history not evidence just
blah blah blah but the viral conspiracy
theory lives on
the kremlin even insists it's one reason
russia invaded ukraine to begin with
president putin has said on numerous
occasions that the threat has come right
to our border said russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov
military laboratories creating pathogens
moscow's baseless claim has been
amplified online and on tv
what exactly are they doing in these
secret ukrainian bio labs you don't know
what they're working on over there see
the us be doing some stuff
a poll found 26 percent of americans
believe it including members of congress
well come to find out in fact it's true
instead what's really killing people is
russia's war fought not just with
bullets and bombs but with
disinformation and deceit
are you afraid that the russian military
could target this pillar possible it's
possible
when we first heard these lies about
bioweapons we thought it was funny she
says but we're not laughing anymore
for cbs morning's chris livesay keeve